Andy, hi Crystal. Good morning.
Good morning. Hi, Crystal.
Yeah, you're on mute, just in case you're talking.
Can you all hear me?
Yep, can now.
Hold on just a second. I'm looking for my...
Head Singh.
Oh.
Sure.
Bear with me just a moment, ladies.
Hey, everyone.
Take your time.
Hi, Natalie.
Hey, how's it going?
I'm a pumpkin today.
You do kind of look like a pumpkin now that you say it.
Okay, I think I can hear you guys now.
Hey, hello, how are you?
I'm well, how are you?
Good. Great. All things are going with.
Friday.
Mhm.
The.
Surviving the storms, Crystal.
We haven't really had storms like Austin and.
North Texas, so...
Okay, a little more, a little more Jerome, yeah.
It's rain, yeah.
Yep.
Okay, we are ready to get started.
Alright.
Yes. So everyone, thank you for joining our bi-weekly service call. So today we're going to be reviewing the week from 4th to 22nd of May. Moving on to the agenda items, that's all the same.
For a quick check-in, this is for you, Crystal. How are things at this moment?
So I did make a comment on the survey that I received. I like for John Matthew to be a little bit more proactive in the sense of tickets not being assigned to him. I know we've discussed this previously before.
I'm having conversations with John Wells, which is the other John, to mention, you know, assigning him level one tickets or tickets that he could work on, but it's a disconnect for some reason between the two of them, right? I just don't have the bandwidth throughout my day to check to see if he's getting tickets assigned.
I just would prefer a like for him to be a little bit more proactive to say, hey, I haven't received a ticket or, you know, my queue is not, you know, full for me to work on. I just need him to say something as opposed to, you know, I get to the end of the week and I see his email.
And, you know, there are a few tickets that he's worked throughout the day, or even at the end of the day, I see that he's worked a few tickets. So I'd like to see a little bit more proactiveness on his part to make mission of, you know, him working tickets. I do know that he has limited access to do certain things that require admin.
you know, credentials for some clients. But even with that, you know, he's aware of this, but he can also work on other tickets that doesn't require admin access.
So.
But other than that, other than that, all is well.
Gotcha.
So Crystal, would you, I mean, I guess there's, I have two questions from this. Dispatcher on your side, is it just our engineer that is having kind of the issue where not always getting dispatched tickets or is it kind of just a...
All right.
issue that you see with John.
No, it's no, it's just John. And I do know that again, he has limited access because let me just set what's going on for his access at the moment. So we have some clients that are just operating from
Yeah.
a Office 365 environment, and then we have some clients that are on-prem, right? The combination between on-prem and Office 365. So our network security engineer was able to set up John Matthew with his own admin access specifically for.
Office 365 clients. But for the on-prem clients is going to take my network security engineer a little bit longer because it requires for him to set up a separate special access for John Matthew, but it's for each individual client. So he has to thoroughly go through the on-prem to set it up. So it's a little bit time consuming.
Unfortunately, you know, our company is small and the network security and the engineer is just one person and not a team of people. So it's just a space of him getting time to actually set up that access for him. So, but to answer your question, yes, essentially it is just John Matthew that
I'm having this issue with because I do know again, he does not have the same access as everyone else, which is why I mentioned to him and the other John, it's okay for him to work on level 1 tickets where if a user calls in and say, hey, my Outlook is having issues, can someone assist me with troubleshooting?
that doesn't necessarily require admin access unless you're uninstalling and reinstalling the software. And even with that, he can also get assistance from someone with the team. So it's just, again, a matter of I'm not seeing more proactiveness from him in a way where he's working more tickets than just one or two tickets throughout the day.
Is he allowed to assign tickets to himself? Like if he goes in there? Like, so, and he, that may be the gap as well, where he's not trying to like step on other John's toes, but if that's acceptable, then we can, is there a certain process to assign a ticket to yourself?
Yeah.
Yes, and because...
No.
So let me just kind of also set the stage of, so his role, right? So typically from 930 AM until 4 PM, he's working tickets. After 4 PM, he is working the dispatch queue where he's dispatching the tickets to other engineers.
Sure.
So his access doesn't get removed from 930 A.m. to 4 P.m., right? But John Wells essentially is the primary person that assigns the tickets, but it's not necessarily a situation where
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can he assign tickets? It's just the fact of him not mentioning that he doesn't have any tickets. That's really where the issue is. Because as you know, he's still learning the team and learning the structure of the team and learning who has experience or skills.
Yeah.
So he wouldn't necessarily know which tickets always that he could take on unless, you know, he's just more familiar with the clients than the other Johns. So again, I just think it's just him just raising his hands to say, hey, you know, I have availability to work on tickets.
you know, can you sign me a ticket or are there any tickets? I don't see that from him. So again, that's the only constructive feedback that I have.
Gotcha, gotcha. Ayra, I'm sure you probably, I mean, you're doing the board review, so I'm sure you've seen that the ticket counts a little bit low here. And yeah, let's just see what our plan is moving forward.
Yes, I completely understand the concern and I actually did reach out to him. So I did try to check out all of his work tickets, so which I will show you in the coming slides under our performance analysis. So probably have to, we probably have to discuss that on.
that slide so we can have the number. Let's move on. OK.
Yeah, you can, yeah, we can jump into it and then we can kind of look at the data and then analyze it as we go.
Yeah.
Okay, so this is for utilization trend. Let's move on to ticket closure. So here we have the chart for the tickets worked on and the tickets closed. So this is for May 4th to 22nd. So I can see that he's been working on a lot of
Tickets lately.
And then I agree with Crystal that there's an opportunity there to close more tickets.
But as I can see, from those three weeks, most of the days he worked on tickets, he was able to close tickets. So I checked in with him. You're right as well, Crystal, that most of your tools, he still doesn't have access. Most of them are.
from Barracuda issues, so he still doesn't have access to Barracuda. And then some other clients, he still doesn't have access to your on-prem, which you have mentioned. So the plan here, I guess, is to wait until he receives the complete access, plus I'll be...
Amit.
monitoring him closely. I told him to reach out to you specifically if he doesn't have tickets on that day, especially if he's doing this patch and then there's no tickets incoming, so he can work on tickets sideways.
Mmh.
Was he reaching out to Crystal or John? Because he should reach out to John first, right? Crystal? Okay.
If, if John is not around, yeah, yeah, this is for for that specific time.
So...
So as it relates to the Barracuda access, I reached out to him yesterday and I asked whether he had experience working with Barracuda and he explained that he has. So I created a ticket for our network security engineer to give him access to attend the university because, you know, in some instances,
Hmm.
I have engineers who say they do have experience, but I don't know when was the last time that they've used it. So I would prefer for them to have, you know, more update training or modules that they could review, especially as it relates to how we support our clients. So I made sure that
We're getting him the access to attend those trainings and to view those modules, video modules, so that once he do begin working those tickets, he's more updated and he's aware of the process.
Okay, you said you have that training that he can go through because we also, Barracudas are sock of choice, so we also have trainings too if you need any help there.
Oh, I didn't know that you all had training, but that that was that was.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that we use, we use Barracuda as our, that's our partner for SOC whenever we're doing like an all-in-one, like we work with pretty much any SOC, but like if we're actually reselling and stuff, so there, yeah, we we can put some training in place.
Okay.
Yeah, so we don't necessarily have training in-house, but Barracuda has a university, right? So that's essentially what access, you know, I asked my team to get him access to so that he can attend those trainings.
Yeah.
OK, so let's.
But if you, if you all have in-house, that would be wonderful.
Yeah, I think it's because I think we do use like their platform, but there's probably an additional layer that we can add in there. So Ayra, just kind of keep this on like it's really a CDP at this point and then figure out who on our side is like the go-to for Barracuda to kind of just be there as he's.
Training U here.
Yep, I'll add that to his CDP and I'll make sure that he will be trained for Barracuda in case he got the access. So he'll be able to work on the tickets and close it actually. So this, yep, sorry, Andy, go ahead.
Um...
Yeah, it's okay. So Crystal, just want to ask, since, you know, both John Matthew and John Wells, both the Johns are doing dispatch, right? So just wanted to know, is it okay or how we can can we tell John Wells that, you know, any sort of L1 or level 1 tickets
will primarily go to John Matthew instead, so that it goes directly. Because I feel like, and then if he doesn't have any access to it, then he can let you know, so that we actually know that yes, he was able to assign the ticket, he was able to work on it, he's seen it.
Yes, so...
Um...
Yes.
But then we've identified that, hey, I don't have access to this, but I wanted to work on it.
Right. And so this is a conversation I've had with John Wells, I know at least three times. I, you know, some with my team, when there's a change of the process, it takes them a little bit longer to catch up with the change. Which, you know, John now, Matthew now working on tickets, it's a change for him. So
I guess it's that.
Mm-hmm.
True.
Mhm.
It's him remembering, oh, I have John. I can assign tickets to John. So it's me having to constantly restate.
Mmh.
that, you know, quite often, I like to explain to him along with others on my team. I just don't have the bandwidth throughout the day to monitor that one engineer's queue to make sure that there are tickets assigned. So if I could just get, you know, participation from John Matthews just to say, hey, you know, I have availability, I haven't received any tickets.
But.
Mhm.
Remind. True.
you know, can I be assigned tickets? That would be a lot more helpful.
Sure.
Yep, which we acknowledge and I hear you. We wanted to make sure that if you don't have any more tickets throughout the day, you ask for it. But there are times also, I'm guilty as charged, to be honest, when I'm working on something, I'm just so into it, I completely forgot that, hey, I have other things to do and I don't have any more tickets.
Yeah.
So yeah, we'll make sure that John communicates better. I think not just to you, but he needs to be comfortable in communicating with John Wells, really, because they need to have that relationship since they're both dispatching tickets. So that's where we're going to coach, maybe, John Matthew with.
Mm-hmm.
Yep.
So, he, he was able to, or he's comfortable in letting John Wilson know that he doesn't have any, and maybe if a ticket, or right now one ticket got routed to a different chair, maybe they can just send it along to to John Matthew, so that he can actually learn it, because the guy is is, yeah, the guy is actually wanting to to learn more, and...
Mhm.
Yeah.
understand more, it's just limiting the access. Oh, also, do you have probably an estimate on when are we getting that access?
Mhm.
I don't. I wish I did. Like I mentioned, our network security engineer is just one person. If we had a team of people, then, you know, we could get more on that progress. But he works on not just internal network security, you know, processes. We work with our clients as well. So it's just a matter of him having
Okay.
Mmh.
Mhm.
With the porters as well.
Mm-hmm.
And then he was out on PTO. It's just, yeah, it's a lot. So yeah, it's a lot. So I am constantly, weekly, hey, where's the progress? Which.
A lot. Gotcha.
Mmh.
You know, at some point, he's going to have to take the time out to get him that access. So, yeah.
Yes.
True.
Okay, gotcha. So I guess...
And actually, while we're talking about it, let me send him a quick hello where things are now.
Okay.
Don.
All right, so I guess the game plan now is to make sure that, you know, they're comfortable talking to each other and ask for more if you don't have any. Gotcha. All right. Yes, and our target for the day for ticket closure really is 8 to 10. So I guess John Matthew understands. So that's the.
Right.
The identity to work on in a daily, so at least he had that baseline, so we'll work on that.
Thank you.
You're welcome. Go ahead, Ayra.
All right, thank you for that. Shall we go back to the slide? Action tracker. Okay, so thank you for submitting your survey for the NPS, Crystal, and the April CSAT feedback for John Matthew.
Kip.
We receive that. So I know you're already aware that for NPS survey, we're doing this quarterly. And then for the CSAT feedback, we're doing that monthly. So we should receive that from Partner feedback. Well, I remind you if in case your feedback or survey is still pending. OK.
Well...
Yeah.
These are the KPIs that we have. You're aware of this, but then I'll make sure to comply on these things once I was able to get all of the data that I need. I'm constantly doing board reviews, so I should be able to complete this, but from this service deck, you should be able to see half of it.
starting with utilization trend. This is just based on the manual tracker that I'm doing. So for, I have the non-billable and the billable trend.
So we can see that across all three periods, non-billable work has been consistently higher than the billable, and that is because he's doing a dispatch, triage and dispatch, right, role. So as we move along, we should be able to increase the billable utilization, especially if the access is complete.
What do you work at?
Yeah.
Any questions for this?
Yeah, no questions, but I just like to make mention that typically he's dispatching 2 hours, I believe. Yes, it's two hours.
Bring that in.
Yeah.
StaAna.
Mhm.
You.
Mm-hmm.
I'm sorry, was that a question?
Hey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just how that would work on your side. Or would you rather him do it like during like the kind of the dispatching time frame?
I think that would be a good time for him to work on that because typically from 4 to 630, he may or may not receive a call. He may get a call because our office hours close at 5. So essentially he's working the ticket.
queue from 5 to 630 only, but as far as receiving calls is from 4 to 5. So he'll have the time to be able to review the videos and go through the training.
OK, good game plan there.
Now, that's unless you, that's unless you struggle with multi-mask. Should I do know that there are some that you know they struggle with multi-mask?
Yeah, unfortunately.
Okay, that's settled then. So we can move on to this slide. We already discussed this, but the average resolution rate or target, Crystal, is 80% here at ITBD by Design. Right now, we're at 42%. Total tickets worked on 83 versus the ticket closed. So that's 37.
Yes, 100.
These are the ticket types that he's been working on, account management, disk capacity alerts, laptop workstation functionality, email and mobile device issues, software installations, request and backup and RMM alerts. So this is a good start actually because
Let me see.
Mhm.
It would be okay.
Go.
Ever since we started, we've been starting to get more complicated tickets like these capacity alerts and RMM alerts. So I will monitor this closely and I'll make sure that we have the CDP placed for Barracuda. So we'll have that added here.
People.
Ohh, I don't, I don't know.
No.
So, the trend is...
Do you by any chance, I'm sorry, do you have by any chance have the ticket number for the software installation? Because I don't believe he has admin access to install software.
Second.
Um, sure, I...
Yeah.
So, get out from the report. Let me show you my screen.
Ha.
on the other side.
Hold on.
Mm.
Can you see this screen?
Yep, I downloaded this from your connect wise manage, so from here.
I'm going to see if the certificate was a question by somebody.
Kip.
For Priya, too.
Yeah.
These are the things that he's been working on. This is just a summary, so...
OK.
Popkin.
If you want the full details and exact tickets, it's up here, right there, but then...
No.
Facebook.
Um, we can take a look.
Yeah, I just wanted to know which ticket number was it that he worked on for software installation, because from what I know, he doesn't have admin access to install software. Do you have a GT number?
Okay.
You don't have to provide it now, but whenever you get a chance to. Let me know. Can I wait?
Sure. You can see this. I don't know what app is this, but it says here, installation of ProCup. Yeah. Claude, please stop.
They should be that right.
ProCal installation. Yeah, if we didn't get the ticket number, let me see if I can find it based on that description. And what was it? ProCal installation.
Yeah.
I already have to see.
Ohh.
Act.
I.
This doesn't include dispatch tickets, right? These are all just worked on.
Yes, work on close or not.
Yeah.
I listen to you.
To.
He did install software. I didn't know he had. Oh, he did it be a Kasper. OK. He did it be a Kasper. OK, so.
He's A logician.
Kaseya allows you to install. Okay, I, yeah, he pushed it from Kaseya. Now I see.
Did he push it from Kaseya?
Okay.
Yeah, okay. I got it now. I understand.
Okay, thank you. I'll go back to our slide. Give me a second.
Are you on that?
The last data.
Four.
Analytics.
Have feeling.
I'll share it again. Give me a second.
Sure.
For the part of the CSAT for this month, we got one CSAT. Let me just show you here.
Bye.
The other assignment.
Sure. I'll just do it this way. It's loading.
Yes.
Ben.
Yeah.
Can you see my screen now?
Yes, we can see. Oh, I can.
Okay, thank you. So this month we got one CSAT. That's a good start. Hopefully for the coming months, we receive more CSATs from your clients. This is from Roxanne Gutierrez from Stewart Tubular Products Company. So that's all for this CSAT.
It's associating a sales rep.
Macatol.
Rather than having like all the sales reps.
One thing.
Yes.
Here for the build it live 2026. I'm not sure if I asked you already. Have you registered already, Crystal?
working.
Play a third year.
I have not.
I'm telling you, I'm...
No, we definitely want to try to get somebody from ECS over. It's going to be awesome. If you know John C. Maxwell is going to be one of our keynotes. We do have the Pre Day peer group. And then our off-site is going to be at the New York Stock Exchange. And I don't know if you like themed parties.
Let me think about.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Blake.
Crystal, but it's going to be a great Gatsby theme, so I'm pretty excited about that. And then AI leadership, big focus on account management too, if that's going to be in our conference this time around.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you, I don't know if you guys sent me an email for that. I can certainly forward it to our leadership team to let them know that that's something to.
Think about for August.
Yeah, and yeah, yeah, for sure. And then actually the Pre Day too, it has the mastermind peer group. And then if you're a partner, we're going to do a little party at Sunny and Camp place. So it'll be fun. I'll send it over to you for sure. Definitely marketing emails have gone out, but I'll make sure that I get you some info and
Each of the Team.
Sure. Thank you.
Okay, thanks for that. Natalie, you're going to send out the email, right? But then I'll also include this slide to the other email that I'll be sending you, Crystal.
Hello.
Yeah.
So OK.
Moving on to the IT By Design products, so you're already aware of this. If you have questions, Team GPS, Pro Services, let us know.
Yeah.
For the way forward, have to, so John remains a reliable presence for your after-hour supports support, helping out triage and dispatch, sharing that clients' issues are triage, routed, and supported. And for the second item here, next service review to allow for a more comprehensive view.
Ohh.
For John's performance, Crystal, are you comfortable moving our bi-weekly meeting to monthly business review?
Yeah, I'm okay with it.
Okay, same day and time, right?
Same day and time. Yep.
Okay, I'll send you the new invite for this one. Thanks for the confirmation. And moving on to the open Q&A. Any questions from anybody?
No questions for me.
No questions, but I think Crystal and the next time that we meet, we have to recalibrate our targets for John and Matthew, because the 80% and the target number of our tickets that we have is for full-time person that is actually working on tickets day in, day out. But since his
No.
Okay.
Sandhu.
The things that he does on a daily basis is a mix of both. So we will be calibrating for the resolution utilization as well, and will include dispatch. We'll try to actually get the first response time so that we can actually gauge if he was able to dispatch tickets in a timely manner.
Okay.
I will be looking.
So at least you have any idea if he's actually effectively dispatching tickets correctly. Okay? And in a timely manner. That's very important. And...
Okay.
Yes.
I am looking to. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
Yeah. It's okay. Bye.
No, I was looking, I was looking to discuss this also with my manager as it relates to the ambiguous of his structure in his title. You know, he's like you mentioned, he's working tickets and also dispatch. So I need to look into what would be the best
Mhm.
Yeah.
But.
targeted or KPIs for him specifically because of his title. So.
Kip.
Okay.
Mhm.
June.
is my homework, my to-do for the next week, and then we'll just share it with you, okay?
Like Amit.
Alrighty, I appreciate it.
Perfect. Natalie, you have anything?
Have a good weekend.
Thank you, you too. Bye-bye.
All right. Happy Friday. Bye.
Thank you, everyone. Happy Friday. Bye.
Bye.
Goodbye.